estamos en la recta final de los
comicios y las polémicas no cesan
hablemos del reporte de este reporte de
la revista action según el cual el
presidente de trump estaría ya listo
para cantar victoria en la noche del
martes él lo niega sin embargo es una
preocupación ya que el mandatario ha
hablado de fraude desde hace meses qué
pasa si en efecto trump se declara
ganador antes de tiempo que seguiría
después
buenos dias valentina bueno yo creo que
además de todos estos análisis y
obviamente encuestas que se están
haciendo hemos visto muchos números a lo
largo de estos días ahora más allá de
esto hay un número bastante llamativo y
que presenta por supuesto lo opuesto
al día de hoy sabemos más allá de todo
que más de 93 millones de personas ya
emitieron su voto anticipado para estas
elecciones en eeuu un número muy elevado
equivale prácticamente al 67 por ciento
de la participación total que vimos en
las elecciones del año 2016 y hay un
fuerte interés por por los comicios y
estos quedando solamente no en horas a
las a las elecciones según las encuestas
a horas de que todo esto suceda yo bailé
en lideraría con bastante claridad las
proyecciones de intención de voto en una
buena cantidad de estados a lo largo del
país 52 por ciento de las personas que
irían a votar o que ya lo hicieron
anticipadamente dice que lo hará por
bailén no frente a un 43 por ciento que
se inclina por por donald trump
y yo creo que en esto en términos de
encuestas como bien decías vemos que
vayan se muestra la delantera de donald
trump de al menos en cuatro estados
decisivos todos ellos en pensilvania y
arizona florida y wisconsin throne ganó
a las elecciones de 2016 no de todas
maneras se llama regularmente a la
cautela en estos términos yo creo que
esto es algo que también debería estar
haciendo el presidente donald trump y
muchos de estos estudios que analizamos
porque recordemos que a veces las
encuestas y los números no nos dicen
verdaderamente lo que lo que va a
suceder no nos olvidemos que en eeuu no
hay una elección sino 51 elecciones nos
eligen por iu a través de colegios
electorales entonces hay que esperar
hasta último momento señora martín vemos
a los candidatos enfocados en los
estados pendulares en este último día de
campaña pero de todos ellos hablemos de
pensilvania por qué es tan importante y
por qué hay temores ante la muy posible
demora de los conteos de los votos por
correo en este estado
bueno en esto yo creo que tenemos que
tener muy en cuenta como bien decíamos
recién cuáles son los estados pendulares
y vuelvo a insistir en el modo que tiene
el modo de sistema este electoral de los
de los eeuu y esto nos va a llevar a por
qué es tan importante y por qué hay
estados que son pendulares y que son
fundamentales no hay que muestran
digamos una trayectoria
a lo largo de la historia de las
presidencias de eeuu y en las victorias
que han sido cruciales a la hora de
definir una elección ahora volvemos
estos datos y como bien decíamos recién
datos que nos dicen poco acerca de cómo
realmente está la carrera presidencial
se puede ir dando no nos olvidemos que
se pueden sacar más votos y a la vez se
pueden perder las elecciones como le
sucedió a hillary clinton en el que
digamos en el voto popular se impuso por
más de 48 por ciento contra 46 pero en
el colegio electoral digamos terminó
perdiendo por 304 a 227 no entonces yo
creo que estos son los detalles que
tenemos que tener en cuenta y cuáles son
los estados
pendulares que van a marcar precisamente
que nos marcan la intención de voto en
los eeuu